our warning this report from sky's rob
powell contains flashing images
not tied now confirmed boris johnson and
carrie simons married yesterday in a
secret
ceremony in central london several
newspapers say the service took place
in front of a small group of family and
friends who were invited at the last
minute
amid strict secrecy and this is the
venue
westminster cathedral around a mile from
downing street
covered rules would have permitted just
30 people to be in attendance here
at the largest catholic church in the
country last night musicians were seen
leaving number 10
with some family members spotted earlier
but inside government officials and
mps were reluctant to comment on the
news
rumors of a relationship between the
couple first emerged in 2018
while the then foreign secretary was
still married to his second wife
by the autumn of 2019 and with boris
johnson now prime minister
the pairing was out in the open with
carrie simons pictured celebrating the
conservatives election win
inside downing street
2020 brought the announcement of the
couple's first child
a baby boy named wilfred and the news
that they were engaged
this will be boris johnson's third
marriage and carry simon's first
and despite a colorful and much
publicized private life
the prime minister still rarely opens up
about what goes on behind closed doors
a reticence that seems to run against
the reputation
of this most public of politicians rob
powell sky news in westminster